leone looks as though it's under a spell
more than 70 light installations have
turned the city on the Rhone River into
a fabulous backdrop full of art and
poetry even those who know the French
city well can now experience it from an
entirely new perspective
one of the high points of the festival
is the light show by Leon based artist
Joe Barracuda but I thought motivate the
whole city flocks to this festival even
if it's cold or snowing even those who
don't get out much come to see it this
is what I thought his own the exhibits
often tell little stories like this one
about the history of cinematography to
pioneers in the field the lumiere
brothers were born in Lyon at the other
end of the city cartoon Inuit have
discovered a playground on the facade of
the city's opera house
about four million visitors hit the
streets of the city during the four
nights of the festival I live in Leon
and usually it's a very quiet city but
now there are tourists from all over the
world here your bathroom back on there
we gotta come to see the light festival
every year that the WF will deposit if
it was originally a religious festival
but then technology slowly got the upper
hand let technology and the religious
roots of the event have now disappeared
almost entirely what is years of public
morale is battered just a few more hours
until the premiere on the plastic tail
hole in the heart of the city joubert
kudin concentrates on his sound check he
is the first artist actually from Lyon
to win the international competition to
provide the central installation well
maybe I shows in the best scene Bundy's
in the [ __ ] we ran through the show 10
times yesterday and everything went well
but we realized that we could improve
things just a little bit more I don't
need vicodin is the founder of the city
classy all artists collective which is
renowned for the large-scale frescoes it
has created in cities all over the world
light design is his new passion let me
meet at the vessel facina it's
fascinating to combine light and color
and movement but you have to pay close
attention as over the course of the show
I want to make people feel think and to
do that you need a story hey don't sky
on scene are you some artists also
rehearsed here in a regional
administrative center until right before
the official opening
french light artist Jean Luc ave here on
the Left turned one modern structure
into a spiritual place a Cathedral of
light and water
okay but then we can review there's no
overarching theme at the festival you're
only limited by the location and the
bounds of your own artistic freedom you
have to transform the location with
light or video effects we work with
lights and synchronize it with a musical
score back to the plus detail where's
your bakudan is bringing paintings to
life he projects artworks from the
museum onto its facade
well don't go no fun at all I'm happy
when people smile feel good and forget
everything for a minute or two and dive
into this dream world it doesn't soak
though I have cansada the power of light
once again the city of Lyon turns
Northern Europe's darkest month into a
celebration
you